welcome back y'all we are very lucky to
have one of the greats with us miss Dion
War
we our next guest is The Talented
musician and Oscar nominated record prer
who's worked with artists like Macy Gray
pink and Beyonce never heard of him I'm
just kidding he also happens to be Dion
son together they have a new single out
now it's called I Neil and they'll be
releasing an album next year called
songs of inspiration please welcome
Damon Elliot
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
man Dion's your mom let's just start
with that that's crazy it's pretty cool
yeah what did you think how old were you
when she scolded Snoop Dog and shook
night oh are we going to that story okay
yeah I'm like I'm still reliving that I
know like we're what year like I think I
was around 1 18
19 right around that Declaration of
Independence time throwing me under the
bus off we the people that's that's how
it starts do you were you ever were you
the kid that like snuck at it all did
you ever get busted did I ever oh man
did I ever that's that's why I got sent
to military school oh you went to
military school you really need to be
straightened out okay did okay okay okay
no but that's that's awesome though um
in the sense of like just growing up
around I don't know just growing up in
their industry so much I I often wonder
about my kids like because they're
always around people and they think it's
so normal like and then you obviously
gravitated to the same line of work sure
was it always in the cards for you like
that did you always I knew from like day
one or at least maybe day six years in
seven years in of my life yeah day one
but um that I wanted to be in music and
I never wanted to be a firefighter or or
police officer I always wanted to do
music I drove my mom absolutely crazy
singing all in the house maybe not being
the best singer in the family just being
honest so I turned into a producer yeah
and it worked out okay it worked out
real well thank
god I'd say so yeah I mean even the
names listed those are incredible names
that you've been able to like work with
over the career and now you're doing
something together who thought of this
who who thought of the idea to do the
gospel album me you did yeah yeah I did
uh it's I feel what we're going through
now
universally people we need some words of
inspiration
and you know
um and coming coming from a gospel
singing family you know understanding
that gospel is actually the Bible and
song yes and I feel that well maybe
we're getting too far away away from the
Bible and what it really means so let's
put some of that back into people's ears
and hearts yeah I love it so what was
inspiration for anal that's the song
right so IAL is a really really uh
personal song to both mom and myself
when I co-wrote the song with Greg and
um Jared and the guys um and actually
was inspired by a young lady who's here
um today her name is Alexis Silva and
and she went through this bout at 15
years old when she was 14 at the time
and it was amazing to see how Mom turned
to God in prayer and I remember she said
specifically to Alexis's father God's
got this and and we just we prayed and
we prayed and we prayed and ironically
the same time when the song was coming
out um she beat what it was that she was
going through and it just shows The
Testament it just shows how how when you
really believe and you really get down
on your knees and pray God will answer
you God's timing yeah it's powerful yeah
um and the timing of that is incredible
how do you dismiss that you know what
I'm saying like how does that don't yeah
I don't dismiss yeah no absolutely so
what what's it like to see I mean it had
you had to be a little nervous with him
going into the business it can be a very
hard business so watching your kid get
involved in that like what is that like
to see him succeed it's wonderful you
know it's like I told them it's if
you're going to do it make sure you're
the best at it you have to hone your
craft it's not given to you you will
earn it and that's exactly what he did
driving her crazy every day playing her
demo after demo after
demo look I apologize to my mom too I
sang so much we had lived in a tiny
duplex so yeah or an apartment so she
was like shut
up and I'm out there like singing aerial
part of your world or something like I
was I never shut up I never but it
worked out mom she does this thing with
her head where if you're not hitting the
right nose it's like kind of like so I I
probably I probably give you some neck
problems my mom would not nod her head
she'd just be like
no she like she's very
truthful but it's working out now it's
working out for both of us now see so if
you have a kid that's driving you crazy
in your home it's going to be fine um we
have to take another break you can
listen to Dion and Damon single I Neil
wherever you get your music and look for
their album as well it's called songs of
inspiration next year that's coming
[Music]
[Applause]
out thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home